you being a new yorker we just saw
rudy giuliani we talked about the
cuomo's pat's first day in your
financial career was the day before 9
11. it's this weekend is now 20 years no
saturday so two days ago tomorrow for me
it's going to be totally oh gotcha 20
years so you being a new yorker we're
talking about rudy i'm just opening it
up for conversation it's a 20-year
anniversary of 9 11. we just left
afghanistan it's all over the news
just there's no specific question but
just what comes to mind when you when
you you know
circulate through all these stories well
listen because i just saw rudy i mean
i i gained a lot of respect for him as
mayor of new york
because he brought that city back
you don't know what he was america's
mayor yes and you don't know what new
york was like prior to that you know
i'll tell you a story i was uh i was out
on i forget if i was
you know i got busted on a parole
violation and i had been out in new york
for several years
and they would drive me back i had to go
in front of judge
henderson morrison here so i was with
the marshals in the car we're driving
back
and uh i said hey guys what time we got
to be in court he said we got a couple
hours i said do me a favor he said what
i said let's drive around i haven't seen
the city in a while i said he's just
what do you want i said i want two
things i want dunkin donuts because i
haven't had that
you're a starbucks guy what's going on
no i was dunking donuts all the way i
said and i want to drive through
manhattan i haven't been here
and when they took me down to times
square i could not believe you know the
reformation
yeah
yeah this was uh right after ju you know
julie giuliani got into office he was
there a couple
my father wouldn't let my my mother
bring
me and my sisters to the city oh it was
terrible
you know that you could get off the
bridge on houston street and i am not
kidding if people of my age know you
would have a hundred prostitutes coming
up to the car right on the street coming
up to the car rolling down your window a
hundred of them every single day
it was smut city it was just terrible
times square you you didn't even want to
go to the theaters it was all peep shows
you know now the main peep show now is a
nypd uh you know department there but it
was terrible
and the reformation of times square
alone what he did there and to clean up
the city the city you know when when
dinkins was the mayor it was it was a
party for us because anything went yeah
anything what we were doing but it was
just a terrible place the bronx was
burning in the late 70s
bronx was the worst city in the country
terrible what comes to your mind
in regards we're talking about 911 new
york your 20-year financial career
everything listen i i so i had the uh by
the way david if you're listening to
this the david you david david david we
got to make sure that uh captain uh uh
tajer goes out on 9 11.
okay uh just make a note of that because
the captain of the spokesperson of uh
apa that's got to go out on 9 11.
got it yeah because one of the things i
asked him i asked him a few different
questions so this the guy that's always
on msnbc cnbc on cnn on follow-up guy
he's everywhere okay yeah captain uh uh
uh tajer is his last name captain taeger
i think it's dennis tager
yeah dennis tager
he's a he's an absolute stunt of a guy
okay and we were having a conversation
he said i asked him about hey so tsa
numbers are up it's only 10 down from
what it was in 2019 so people are
traveling again
uh you know should we feel safe travel
again a lot of private jet businesses
charters taking off right now are you
worried about he says no i want the
wealthier to get wealthier because the
more money the rich make my business
takes off so i'm like very interesting
as a union guy to say something like
that
and then we went and talked about a few
other things and then finally i talked
to him about 9 11 i said so
question for you in regards to 911 do
you worry with what happened with
afghanistan
with the taliban that another 9 11 could
potentially happen
and and if yes how are we prepared for
it you know what is difference between
today and then i mean obviously we know
tsa george bush came out with tsa
november of 01 two months after 911
camera we didn't have tsa before it was
just kind of like you went on a flight i
don't if you remember it was a lot
smoother you didn't take two hours to
prepare to go on a flight boom and you
went out you could also go to someone's
like if your friend was coming in
pick them up you don't have to go
through this very different but now some
people say it's good some may say it's
bad the reality is it's longer to get on
a flight but at the same time it's safer
right so you're going through it much
harder to do a romantic gesture yeah
sure so i said so how much harder is it
today to conduct a another 911.
and he started talking about stats he
says first of all there's certain things
that we have on every flight that i
can't tell you about now you need to
know on every flight there's a federal
agent and you walk through it on
certain investments on every single
flight there's a federal agency he says
on every flight there's a federal agent
wow is what he's saying now whether
that's true or not maybe it's not maybe
it's my misunderstanding the way he said
it is there's a federal agent on every
flight
and then at the same time they have a
method he says but there's one thing
that he was pissed off about that he
wanted them to pass the bill and the apa
is right now doing something to pass the
bill is for every one of these planes to
invest ten thousand dollars to create
another layer of protection in case
somebody decides to
do something so they can have ten
minutes to be able to prevent the
whoever is trying to take over the plane
for that to not become a reality so
there's one other layer that he wants to
add to it but he says look i'm not going
to lie to you we are paranoid like you
wouldn't believe we still worry about if
the another 911 could happen or not so
you ask that question for me i think in
the last three weeks it just became more
the pers if their odds in vegas where
you can bet on another 911 happen in the
last three weeks it went up
it went up you know how all of a sudden
hey the lakers traded and they picked up
you know uh anthony davis the line just
went 21 to 3-1 okay so if you bet the
week before your head the line of today
another 9 11 happened uh went higher
yesterday we're having dinner and your
wife says i'm not traveling on 9 11. i
just feel weird traveling on 9 11. you
know now what she also said it could be
the safest day of the year if you're
traveling because everybody's more
paranoid but still that thought is there
that they feel the same way yeah so you
wouldn't travel online i'm not no i mean
i'm here i'm not going home
would you want your wife your kids your
family traveling all night not if you
want peace of mind no i don't think
that's something that it doesn't give
you peace of mind traveling on 911 right
i think
but i i would actually probably think
that we are on red alert on 9 11 20-year
anniversary
everything's on reddit i don't know i
don't know if i don't know if i buy that
because let me explain to you everything
about how the how to afghanistan
experience was handled it was so sloppy
to me it says everything else is sloppy
i had a
call the other day when i see suite
executives and we were talking about
something i told a couple of our leaders
i said i said
success softens people up right
so when you win and you're like oh my
gosh i just made a million bucks yeah i
just made 10.
and when you get comfortable and
arrogant
you are officially
exposed and somebody can exploit you
if i'm an enemy and i don't like america
matter of fact if i'm an enemy and i
hate america okay
if there's ever been an administration
that is handling things in a sloppy way
that if you wanted to do some damage to
america unfortunately
unfortunately this is the season yeah
unfortunately because you're sitting
there with your opponent you're like
dude what is the matter like imagine
you're dating a girl
and and you go to a girl a girl's house
and you want to meet her dad and you see
the dad he's like i'm sorry what's your
name i'm adam okay what do you do for a
living
i'm in school do you have a job yeah i'm
18 years old uh you going to school i am
what are you majoring in i want to be an
accountant why do you want to be an
accountant my dad's an accountant uh oh
so tell me about some of you tell me
about your mom and dad uh my mom's a
nurse my dad are they still married
they've been married 22 years do you
have any siblings i have a sister okay
good so he goes through a series of 45
questions like what the hell is wrong
with this guy right and then he says i
want you to meet my son then a 28 year
old son shows up how are you adam i'm
john shakes your hand hey this is my
sister it's my only sister i just want
to make sure you know that if anything
happens to my sister whatever you do to
my sister i'm going to do to you just so
you know that okay great so you leave
right now you go to another girl's house
you go in oh hey adam mary told me about
you you want a drink you want me to get
you something you guys have some fun
tonight grab the keys
you as a boy who has one thing in mind
you're saying what dude slam dunk i
don't need to worry about the dad with
the second girl or a brother but the
first one [ __ ] if i do something the dad
and the brother is gonna come after me
i'm not doing nothing with jackie but
hey mary let's go out i don't have to
worry about you
jackie is biden
that's america today ain't nobody afraid
today and that's a scary thought
um that's a scary thought yesterday
uh trump was on who's the late night guy
gut feel what's uh
yeah gut feel
and they were talking to each other and
gutfield asked the question says look i
was never a fan of you and he says i
never supported you gutfield because he
said a lot of bad things about him says
no i understand i said but i think maybe
eventually you started liking me and
maybe even loving me to say i don't i
don't love you maybe there's operations
got phil's talking to who uh trump yeah
so they're talking face to face and then
uh uh
uh gutville asked do you think it's
important for us to for uh the enemy to
fear the leader he says i don't know
about fear i think it's about competency
and respect
i don't know if the enemy is sitting
there saying these guys are competent
enough to handle
uh nine eleven next nine eleven so how
could that concerns me a lot in regards
to the vice president who can't get
asked even a semi hard question without
breaking out into some sort of maniacal
laughter cackle like she's the joker got
jen sackey coming out yesterday saying
there's gonna be new mandates and uh she
gets asked a really simple follow-up is
this gonna have an effect on everyday uh
american people and she looks like the
grinch furrows or brows and goes only
the unvaccinated
like this is what we're dealing with
like it's it's like comical it's like
the villains have taken over gotham it's
almost like on the comic book you know
what patrick people ask me you know
you're a staunch republican i'm not a
staunch republican i'm for who i believe
is going to be the bet do the best job
for the country you know i have to say
this
this is the worst leadership in my
lifetime by far
i mean not even close that's great you
live through carter i mean that's yeah
that's a big statement these people
appear to be so incompetent they they
can't get out of their own way it's
scary
i really you know
i was thinking about i was going to put
something together you know in the
opening line of the gotti movie it's
it's brilliant where amanda is in jail
he's talking to the guy through the uh
glass and he said 20 years from now
they're going to miss kozanostra 20
years from now they're going to miss
john gotti it's like i want to flash
back and say three years from now
they're going to miss the republican
party three years from now they're going
to miss donald trump
not because of
just because of the way he ran the
country that that's it you know and i i
it drives me crazy republican democrat
you got to put the guy in that's doing
the best job for the country that's it
it's not a question of per for me it's
never about personality it's about
policy
that's it what's best for my country for
my kids and my grandchildren
that's what i look at
i went i went to a uh oyster place in
boston we walk in
hostess shows up gives an attitude to me
and mario
i said to her i said you know what i
said you're not a hostess
you may be a good person in the back you
may be good at handling accounting you
may be good at monitoring stuff on
camera to see if anybody's stealing
anything you may be somebody that can do
a lot of other things you were never
meant to be a hostess
so i said don't take this as don't be
offended by this i had an assistant once
a guy's name is huten good looking
persian kid
the worst assistant i ever had i love
the guy till today he knows that i talk
about him so i said hutan i got good
news i got bad news for you he says
which one do i say which one do you want
he says i want the bad news i said
you're a terrible employee
and he says why i said i said i'm your
assistant he said i'm telling you what
you need to do for me i said this is
pathetic
i said you want the good news he says
yeah what's the good news i said the
good news is you're a butterfly
you're free go do whatever you want to
do says god i'm so glad you said this
because i want to go
surf every single big wave around the
world you did that for seven eight years
happiest kid alive met a girl introduced
me to her when i was in santa ana they
got married he's the happiest camper out
there what's my point here
joe biden's not a good number one he
could be a good number eight a good
number five i think i'm sure 43 years of
experience is going to give a lot of
insight here's what happened here's what
happened fine he's not a good number one
there's a very big difference between
being a number five a number eight a
number one people learned a long time
ago you could not win a championship
building around carmelo anthony as great
as he was
you cannot win building around certain
players this was a topic with my friend
steve avedyan and he would say i would
say i think you can build a team around
russell westbrook he says you have no
clue what you're talking about i said
what are you talking about he says you
cannot build around russell westbrook to
win a championship
he needs to be a two or three for you to
win a championship look at the way this
guy broke and by the way this argument
was seven years ago
six years ago who's right he's right so
i don't know i think we forget that the
number one job
isn't everyone's job we have to come up
with a criteria on what it is to be
number one and as much as i understand
well you know he's a nice guy he's cool
he's this he's that
when you're running a country that's a
as big as it is today and you got people
who hate you because you've been
dominating for such a long time you do
not want to be a have a guy that's
leading that that's a softy that isn't a
bit paranoid that doesn't have the
energy that doesn't have the audacity to
sit there and ask and answer the tough
questions you need somebody that can
lead that it's not everyone's job
there's actually one of the most famous
quotes in uh the sopranos about that
tony soprano is getting into christopher
mossanti's uh getting into him and james
get the late james gandolfini was
phenomenal on that role and he basically
says exactly that he's like you have no
idea what it's like to have to make all
the decisions no way and then at the end
of the day after you made them you've
got to live with them and you and you
alone is that something that you'll
never have to deal with do you remember
at the end of last dance when michael
started crying
do you know that scene where he's like
you know what
you know you don't want this life you
don't want this life there you didn't it
is what it is and i i wanted it i wanted
her to win he says
we need to take a break he just got up
and walked out yeah and i just felt that
right now my body just even thinking
about that entire scene right look
everybody wants to be a number one until
they're number one and they say [ __ ] i
don't want to be a number one heavy
heavy the crown it's not everyone's job
how is it heavy the head that wears if
you go to smithsonian they show the
whole evolution of what happened to uh
lincoln i don't know if you've seen that
in in the from the first year he got
elected to like second year 30 or 40 if
you've never seen that
yeah it's not everyone's job it but he
was during a civil war i mean and and
that's a real tough time to be a
president where he was going trying to
find his own until he found his a
general grant he met well he couldn't
count on he couldn't count on any of
those guys but it's not everyone's job
to be number one well michael you said
something before about you know you
don't care about whether it's democrat
or republican you just want the right
person for the job and what you were
talking about before adam what i
remember most about 911 uh is right
after it happened you know i grew up in
the shadow of the towers towers were
beautiful the freedom tower was gorgeous
don't get me wrong but there was just
something about those two towers sitting
at the end of the at the end of the
island there and i grew up 15 miles
outside the city we saw him come down
and in the in the carnage in the
wreckage my uncles were in their
firefighters and and you know my my both
of my uncles and my grandfather local 40
they worked on towers they built them
and then they were part of the the
cleanup
everything was gray it's it's a
devastating picture you look at it when
when the towers come down there's so
much ash you actually can't tell who's
black who's white you can't tell what
race you or you're just it's people that
they look like they just got through a
12-round fight they're walking around
like my god what just happened and then
10 days after to kind of put a bow on
this we started with baseball i was at
uh i'm sorry it was i think it was 13
days after
we went to a funeral for my dad that
worked in downtown we went to a funeral
and then we went to a
to a mec game after against the braves
and had this massive comeback and piazza
hit a home run and it was like
i don't know if uh if anybody ever sees
it or goes on youtube watch piazza's
home run
place from crazy ugh the whole country
you had sammy sosa
running with the uh
sorry the uh the flag it was amazing
there was no democrats there was no
republicans
no white no black we were americans we
don't have that today though they we
kept saying never forget man 20 years
later we forgot dude and it's only that
the democratic party today is not what
it was 20 30 years ago it was a
legitimate party today you can't even
call it democrats anymore progressive
liberal left whatever it's a different
party the party of john f kennedy and
prior to that different than what it is
that's not what your country could do
for you that's what you could do for
your country democrats saying that that
today got it you know nasa just gave 10
bucks and he says patch pat you're a
warmonger
just because we left afghanistan does
not mean 9 11 will happen quite the
opposite also 60 israelis were arrested
on 9 11. stop the bs okay
so 60 israelis
arrested on 9 11. so the meaning they
they also had some level of involvement
and us i will tell you this and we've
had an [ __ ] before when you talk
about palestine he's palestinian oh do
you remember anas when he talked to the
other uh israeli and they were going
back and forth with the whole okay uh
challenge so we know the optics of where
hanas is at and us this is what i will
tell you i have no desire to be in
afghanistan we should have never gone
the first place we understand there was
a business element to what happened in
afghanistan there's a lot of money being
made in afghanistan a lot of nice
contracts that was being made in
afghanistan i don't know i don't know
the details too but some of the
conspiracies don't sound like
conspiracies they sound like things that
actually could have happened and i give
it some credence what i care about is
sequencing i said it yesterday on
facebook i don't care about staying in
afghanistan i care about sequence and
when a leader gets sloppy
when a leader gets sloppy and is not
competent to know what are his next 5 10
15 moves on leaving afghanistan you can
give 10 different leaders and tell them
we want to leave afghanistan we're going
to do a case study right now you and
your team go in that room you and your
team go in that room you and your team
go in this room in the next two hours i
want everybody to come out with one
spokesperson of each camp talk about
what is the best most optimum way to
leave afghanistan ready go to your teams
everybody goes in their offices two
hours everybody comes back johnny has uh
team number one team number two team
number three and they say here's what i
think we need to leave afghanistan then
the person that's moderating that group
says i think the best plan was given by
three seven and nine let's map out the
15 moves your move number three could be
catastrophic that's the mistake this
isn't about us staying there the mistake
is sequencing and sequencing only
happens
in the wrong way when the leader is
casual no energy afraid and hides that's
the problem what happened with
afghanistan's 100 sequencing problem and
that's why now we have to hear all the
stories 83 billion dollars of equipment
that was left behind to those guys for
what
why why would military go first why
would they not go last so so this isn't
a conversation about you know all the
other methods while they're demanding
3.5 trillion dollars in new and now
human infrastructure they just leave 90
billion behind the administration is
asking about well hey the taliban you
don't have enough women in your
administration what the hell are you
talking about like what are you talking
about what does that matter do you even
think they like do you think they care
do you know how they view women in the
country where i came from like how do
you think these guys view women if you
only knew
if the if if the left only knew how they
treated women and the lgbtq community
you would fully be on a different side
if you know how they treated gays
lesbians and women in the country uh
with all this mess that's taking place i
mean patrick you know what that is all
that is is deflection
you know they're pandering to their base
trying to get women on their side
deflecting what's really going on there
that's what they do all the time
everything is a deflection you know it
it's mind-boggling that some of the
things that you just said the chaos that
was there i i can't understand it i i
don't know afghanistan now yes
can i say one thing there's no right
because obviously we've been kind of
going down a path here let me just put
some facts out there and this might be
controversial whatever
we're leaving afghanistan okay
i think even the left
or i don't even like using left or right
i think even mainstream media is calling
out biden for how sloppy this is
certainly it could it could have gotten
better
different perspective
obviously we all want to bring americans
home
have our allies be safe
short term it's a [ __ ] show
long term though
who do we really need to be focusing on
not so much the middle east anymore we
need to be focusing our attention on
china just double the troops size in
syria dude okay hear me out here
they took the troops out of against and
they moved them to syria okay it's not
like they came home but the big picture
is we need to be focusing on china
and
you know a problem in our government is
we can't walk and chew gum at the same
time i know we've got 800 bases all over
the world the real problem these days is
not the middle east it's the far east so
if it takes
getting ugly and messy in afghanistan in
the short term for long term to wake up
and say
china's the real threat these days
china's the real enemy
long term there might be some major
benefits there so that's just a
different perspective nobody's happy of
what's happening in afghanistan right
now but then again for the last 20 years
nobody gave two shits about afghanistan
we all wanted to get out of there so
like i said on a couple podcasts ago
it's very easy to get into awards very
ugly and hard to get out of a war
especially when it's profitable you
don't want to get out when 24 trillion
dollars are spent in 20 years and 21
of that 24 trillion go to private
defense contractors
and now it's going to be someone else's
mess to clean up yes again an ugly exit
but now pakistan
china
india russia this is a regional
situation we have the luxury of having
two beautiful oceans one that's very
cold on the left side one that's very
warm on the
on the right side
to you know secure our borders whereas
in the middle east and in the far east
it's all intertwined and it's this is
china's problem now or india's problem
or pakistan's problem
thankfully hopefully long-term not an
american problem hey the problem is
though you know i i think it was a lot
less of a problem before this chaotic
exit that we had and now it could be
another breeding ground for terrorism
and you got to understand this and
patrick you should bear me out they
don't hate anybody as much as they hate
america that's agreed
so i think
whether we're there or not there they're
still going to hate us yeah i understand
but they have more power now
they have more leverage okay we can
still be
we can still take down terrorists like
we've been doing for decades and decades
and decades without having to build a
nation we were never going to rebuild a
democracy in afghanistan it was never
going to happen let me ask this so
whether we said we're leaving on this
day or this day or just kind of like
leave in the middle of the night the
taliban's not going anywhere you guys
have both
ran large companies you guys have both
been in charge of hierarchical
structures right when you look at your
competitors and you see them mishandling
situations like this
does something go off inside of you is
it like blood in the water for sharks
and you say okay we need to exploit this
while it's happening now is this
something that catches your attention
when you're when your competitors are
fumbling the ball this bad or or is this
something where you say you know
what's the what's the greater play here
like maybe maybe there's a greater
strategy at play oh for me absolutely
especially on the street when you see
weakness in in your competitor you
strike that's it 100 percent
sun tzu says when an enemy is about to
make a big mistake to fall get out of
their way okay
so which means uh just you don't even
need to get in the way they're gonna
they're gonna yeah now in sports
never stop an enemy from never
never
let a uh uh what do you call it they uh
what is an interception called it's
called the turnover never let a turnover
go to waste like you see how a guy you
got possession do something about it
capitalize you screwed up right so you
know the whole atlanta falcons against
brady the year they were supposed to win
i said what the hell you guys doing you
just keep giving 15 plays that could
have gone the other way you would have
won that too he's like when they were
passing what the hell are you doing
so i i don't think there's a right
answer i think it's all on situational
of where you're at in a situation like
this i agree with you by the way nasa i
heard your second comment this is pat
now that you said it this way i agree
with you but going back to what you said
uh adam i agree with you uh because
here's where we're at here with the
entire situation
so
the number one enemy in the world for us
us's soon number one china okay china
the democratic party some appeal some
people well first of all no you know
alexander said i have so there's no
there's no difference in the democratic
party alexander alexander said i have
met the enemy it is i alexander said
i've met the enemy it is so america's
biggest enemies themselves but let's set
that aside after us being our own worst
enemy
then it's who china taliban came out and
said our biggest ally is who china so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]